foreign
[Music]
so I wanted to be a nurse since I think
I think I was about four years old my
dad actually has a pretty serious back
injury when I was young and so he spent
a lot of time in the ICU and I remember
the nurses there made me feel so
comfortable and I realized hey I want to
be the person to make others feel
comfortable coming from an immigrant
family I was really interested in really
changing how we talk about mental health
and also talking about the opportunities
that I have to the stigmatize mental
health in my community so that was
really important to me as a nurse I get
this incredible privilege it's
completely transformed me I've grown in
confidence I've grown in self-awareness
I've grown to understand what my purpose
is and the population in which I want to
practice nursing allows us to have a
unique and
um
intimate look into people's lives I
don't just want to be a provider I want
to lead people and I believe at Yale I
get the opportunities to learn how to be
the right type of leader I want to
become that I want to do on a national
level whatever I'm doing in 10 years it
could be for the CDC could be for the
White House you're going to see my name
and they're going to know I went to Yale
I think of nursing as the family
profession
my mother was a nurse but you know my
grandfather was a nurse after his little
store on the Lower East Side of New York
was wiped out in the depression
he then
developed a profession of caring for
elderly and Ill individuals my wife's a
nurse I have a very strong sense of what
it means to be a nurse it is a it is an
altruistic work of serving people in
moments when they are in most need of
help and so when I think of the nursing
school I think of the service that they
render to to all parts of our community
during covet every one of the people
that gave me a vaccine was somebody who
was a student at the Yale nursing school
we support the nurses and the nurses
support us and that service makes a huge
difference to the communities in which
we live so Yale's primary purpose
is to improve the world today and for
future Generations
that is a mission of every nurse who
graduates from Yale they do it by
Leading organizations
they do it through advanced practice
they do it through clinical service they
do it through a nursing education
they do it through science but they are
all focused on improving the world
that's what Yale is all about that's
what the Yale School of Nursing is all
about
you come to nursing because you have
this incredible need to be part of
humanity and to
bring Health to all kinds of different
people Julia be a nurse be a nurse
practitioner be a mom and also Inspire
the next generation of nurses I mean
that's huge we bring dedication and
passion for the work
alongside of this desire to to bring
change to the system at large and to
open ourselves to approaching Health
Care from different perspectives what I
see is just such an exciting view of the
future of what they want to do right and
how much they want to take on and how
much they want to improve health for all
this is the call of nursing the ability
to impact change the ability to conduct
research that is important not only to
myself but also to the health and
well-being of others we need to be
thinking about not just Illness but
wellness and not just Wellness but what
does it mean for a person in the context
of their life what we're looking for in
The Next Century is who we are
continuing to become and that that is
what makes this place ever exciting I'm
just passionate about age
generation of nurses we have varieties
opportunities to make some
transformational impacts all the way
across the world I understand in one
word
pioneering impactful trailblazing
exciting empowering inspirational it's
leadership the people unique Community
Integrity resilience opportunities
Innovation it's where tradition and
Innovation cross each other and come
together to contribute to the betterment
of our society
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon and welcome to the
official kickoff of the Yale School of
Nursing centennial celebration I am
Melissa galinato a member of the
Centennial planning committee and a
second year pediatric nurse practitioner
Primary Care student it is an honor to
be the first to welcome you to this
exciting moment in the school's history
and to introduce president salave on
behalf of my nursing and Midwifery
classmates I like to say what a
remarkable achievement it is to be here
given the diversity of our backgrounds
and unique experiences I look forward to
witnessing how we collectively
contribute to the advancement of
wireson's mission of better health for
all people when I along with the rest of
class of 2024 graduate in the spring we
will follow nearly 6 000 alumni into all
aspects of Health Care MSN graduates
will become clinicians in every
imaginable care setting our doctor of
nursing practice degree recipients will
lead Health Systems and influence Health
Care policy those of us who earn a PhD
will continue to teach the next
generation of providers through
interprofessional and education research
and practice it is clear why Sun alumni
have and will continue to innovate lead
and transform Health Care in ways not
imaginable for nurses 100 years ago
and now it is my privilege to introduce
the 23rd president of Yale Peter salovey
president saliva has both celebrated and
championed why Sun's Mission and our
values in nursing and Midwifery in the
summer he attended the disaster
simulation for our first year Gap in
students and eagerly delved into
conversations to learn about the
students intense experiences president
salovey firmly believes in the impact of
our chosen past so much so that he and
his loved ones endowed a style of a
family nursing scholarship here at Yale
all right Yale School of Nursing it is a
privilege to have such a dedicated
advocate for why I stand in the top
position at this University and we
welcome his presence here today as a
testament to why sense integral role in
shaping Yale's future I invite you to
read the rest of his formal biography in
our program and allow him to share more
about his commitment to supporting ysn I
would now like to welcome to the podium
president saliva
[Applause]
well thank you very much for that kind
introduction I very much appreciate it
and good afternoon everyone it's so nice
to see you all and all supporting the
school in its 100th year
it's
an enormous pleasure to be part of the
great history of the Yale School of
Nursing and I very much
have been looking forward to this
Centennial moment I'm also delighted
that with us today are Yale School of
Nursing faculty Yale School of Nursing
staff members students alumni who are
now practitioners other Educators other
researchers I'm delighted you're all
with us today and I'm especially
delighted that our new Dean has arrived
azita amami and so uh
and it's so great to see you as well on
that perfect time for a handoff is at
the 100 year mark right
98 not enough 102 maybe too many 100 is
perfect 100 is perfect
I'm also delighted uh that uh Rajiv Shah
is with us from the Rockefeller
Foundation he'll make some remarks in a
few moments but uh it's very meaningful
uh for us to have him here uh with us
because because the Rockefeller
Foundation was here right from the
beginning he'll tell you a little bit
more about that history but it was gifts
from the Rockefeller Foundation that
essentially allowed Yale to create uh
this school
well 1923 a hundred years ago what was
happening
the foundation Rockefeller foundation's
goldmark report
suggested that a transformation in
nursing education was needed the word
they used to describe Nursing education
up to that time was inadequate
not that's the word they used the report
wasn't inadequate and in partnership
with the Rockefeller Foundation
early nursing leaders like Dean Annie
Goodridge set out to make this the
solution
make Yale the solution to those
inadequacies in nursing education
so we became the first school to offer a
full educational experience for nurses
in training rather than an
apprenticeship program
uh the curriculum that Dean Goodridge
and others pulled together
talked about future nurses and this is
amazing that this is a hundred years ago
this language future nurses as
scientifically informed
technically expert and socially
experienced
right it still it still sounds like
exactly what we do today in the School
of Nursing and in fact there's a whole
history of nursing leadership that
came from this school I won't go over it
with you I'll just mention one uh Dean
Florence Wald who brought the hospice
movement from England to the United
States I mention it because Brantford
hospice celebrates its 50th Anniversary
this same year that we celebrate our
100s
um
Yale was when Yale opened admission for
students with a bachelor's degree but no
prior background in nursing through what
is now called Gap in
The Graduate entry pre-specialty program
uh that was a first by 1975
Yale School of Nursing has 10 specialty
programs and tracks
was at the Vanguard of the nurse
practitioner and nurse Midwifery
educational movement at The Graduate
level
fast forward 100 years forward and
nursing is making the School of Nursing
is making all kinds of contributions
across the university let me pick just
one as many of you know we have a
planetary
Solutions initiative the planetary
Health Initiative within planetary
Solutions
is
a touch point for the School of Nursing
how do
essentially deal with the way in which
climate change is affecting uh human
health
when I think about the next Century of
the Yale School of nurses nursing I'm
optimistic I think nursing's centrality
to this University and nursing as a
profession centrality to improving the
world now and for the future is just all
too obvious so in the film you heard
about my family I sometimes say nursing
was the family business in in in in our
family my former brother-in-law was a
nurse who heard about that my
grandfather's story is interesting after
he was wiped out in the depression
when my grandfather used to talk about
being wiped out he had a little store
that was maybe about 500 square feet and
it went bankrupt in the depression but
but he didn't have anything to begin
with really so that was on the Lower
East Side of New York and and as you
heard to make a living He just cared for
people and he had no formal education
but in those days on the testimony of
your clients
you could get a license as an LPN
and uh like and I always used to joke I
actually I have it but I used to say my
my grandfather was a New York State LPN
number two or something like that he had
to have been one of the first men uh uh
to be licensed as an LPN uh but he was
and he was he talked about his patients
and he talked about what he had learned
kind of in the trenches of nursing uh
all my childhood and so my mother who
married into that family uh and he
always had a special relationship
because my mother uh as you heard was a
nurse she went to uh uh what was what is
formerly called Jewish hospital and
Medical Center of Brooklyn but everybody
calls it Brooklyn Jewish doesn't exist
anymore and uh had that old style of RN
education that wasn't university-based
and was more Apprentice oriented but my
childhood I was a latchkey child because
we came home from school my brother and
I and we uh made ourselves a snack and
we waited for our mom to come home from
the hospital
where she was working with a practice
where she was working ultimately she
moved into geriatric nursing toward the
last maybe 20 years of her profession
and was the director of nurses at uh
geriatric Hospital's first didn't well
by that time we left New Jersey we were
now in Buffalo New York and later in Los
Angeles
um
the stories that my grandfather told
that my brother-in-law told that my
mother told made an impression on all of
us in my family
and helped us I think appreciate how
rewarding
the profession can be
and I know our students feel that way
but also how complex it is
and I would say in more recent years how
in need of improvement our Health Care
system is
well
it was the Public Health crisis ushered
in by covid
that I think helped every one of us who
is not
a nurse or a public health professional
like my wife is or a physician helped
all of us who are not in in the Health
Professions truly appreciate
truly appreciate how hard this work is
how needed this work is
and how in short supply
this work is we're still recovering
we're not out of the pandemic and and uh
further we're still recovering from the
effect that the pandemic had on our
Workforce in the Health Professions
and so a hundredth anniversary comes you
don't plan it for a particular time it
comes in the 100th year
but the universities
response to the 100th anniversary the
fact that we are matching gifts to the
school
the idea that we are celebrating the
centrality of the school
I think is not an accident in coming in
these years as we recover as a society
from this Global pandemic well everyone
who is here today
has been involved in helping position in
some way
the Yale School of Nursing
at the center of Yale University
and help reposition the profession
as at the center of
Health Care
as delivered in this country and
throughout the world and I thank you for
all of that hard work and I thank you
for letting me be a part of both today's
celebration but this larger Mission and
these larger goals as well
so thank you all very much for being
here today and congratulations to the
school
thank you now I'd like to introduce our
next speaker who is the L School of
nursing's new Dean Dr azita amami so
azita is an internationally recognized
nursing leader nursing investigator
she's had a career dedicated to
fostering Wellness she's had two more
than two decades in leading uh
research and teaching in University
settings this is not
what's the expression this is not your
first rodeo this is not your first rodeo
this is her third Dean ship and we are
so fortunate
uh that she can build on Anne's
accomplishments and lead us into the
next uh Century of nursing
responded when I called her and asked
her would you like a third Dean chip and
she ultimately said yes her work is
focused quite a bit on the social
determinants that affect health and
wellness as a part-time health
psychologist that appeals to me greatly
she's a trustee of the Robert Wood
Johnson Foundation she's been an
advocate for Health Equity and
accessibility for Quality Health Care
for all people
and in fact Quality Health Care beyond
the nursing profession I know she is the
Right leader for the school's second
century so please join me in welcoming
thank you very much president Sullivan
for those very kind words and good
afternoon everyone it's such a pleasure
to be with you today
I would like to begin by land
acknowledgment
to initiate our
conversation
yeah
Yale School of Nursing is situated on
the land of the past and present
Quinnipiac people
it is with deep gratitude that we honor
the land people history and traditions
of the indigenous peoples Who stewarded
and the land for generations and who are
still connected to the land as well as
the responsibility that comes with
sharing the land
we acknowledge the painful history and
with our mission at Yale School of
Nursing of better health for all people
we embrace the commitment to health
Justice and care for all communities
especially those who suffer unacceptable
Health disparities
so a centennial celebration honors the
past
but it also
is an appropriate occasion to Envision
the future that will be built on that
past
I want to take a few moments today to
share with you
um the future I see for the School of
Nursing and how the past makes that
future possible
I see a future where nursing leads the
way on promoting Wellness rather than
focusing and addressing illnesses
I see a future where better health for
all people becomes a reality
my vision
of the future sees the Health Care
system in which everyone feels
comfortable
respected welcome and understood because
we have educated nurses to create that
environment
my vision
of the future sees vastly improved
access to healthcare because nurses are
practicing to the full scope of their
capabilities
including delivery delivering
urgently needed Primary Care to
historically underserved populations
and perhaps most importantly
I see a future in which our advocacy
results in addressing the many social
determinants of Health that are the root
cause of disparities of alcohol in
outcomes and a lack of Wellness for many
people
these disparities are not new
nor will they be easily eliminated
these are deeply entrenched realities
reflecting the structural and systemic
inequities resulting from racism
classism and inequitable access to of to
the resources people need to live and
thrive
at Yale School of Nursing
We Are The Heirs to a legacy of
innovation
creativity and advocacy
Yale School of Nursing was founded as a
break from the past as president
Sullivan shared with you
for the first time nursing was an
academic discipline with his own body of
knowledge to be taught and mastered
nurses were no longer just a source of
cheap labor for the medical Wards they
were now educated to provide care that
enable people to get better
this was believe me or not a
groundbreaking concept
our first scene Annie Goodrich was the
first female Dean at Yale
we were among the first nursing schools
to Grant a master's degree and to
require prior nursing experience to
admission
in the 1970s we introduced the idea of
graduate entry pre-specialty nursing
gapan program
and at that point of time just thinking
about making a non-nurse
an advanced nurse
practitioner in three years it was
something that no one would believe
in to be accomplished but we did it
our Legacy of leadership
continues today mostly recently with the
launch of the brand new online MSN
program
Yale School of Nursing began breaking
barriers at his Inception and has never
stopped doing so
we will continue adding to that to that
admirable Legacy as we enter our new
century
I believe there is a widespread
consensus
that the American Healthcare Healthcare
System is not delivering
optimal results
there's less consensus about how to make
it better
well the short answer is Nurses
as one of the leading schools of nursing
we have an opportunity and an obligation
to educate the nurses who will lead in
creating change and delivering better
health for all people
Yale School of Nursing was a paradigm
shift at his Inception
and we will be the we will be that once
again in our second century
our nurse graduates will continue being
compassionate capable clinicians they
will also be powerful
persuasive advocates
inquisitive accomplished researchers
inspirational Educators capable and
creative policy makers respected and
respectful community members and above
all else
leaders in
redefining what Wellness is and how it
can be made the standard of care
today's theme is imagining The Next
Century for of better health for all
people
I want to do more than just imagining it
I Want To Make It Happen by Leading a
school of nursing that shares a vision
of a future of Wellness Equitable access
to health care and a system of care that
lives up to Promises of equity made at
this country's Foundation
make no mistake
getting to that goal is challenged is
very challenging task
but for a century Yale School of Nursing
has identified and met challenges in
healthcare
it's who we are and it's what we do
we can thank our predecessors for the
Legacy and we can best honor them by um
committing to following the in their
food spots footsteps and looking forward
not a way
we cannot accept as insurmountable the
divisions and equities of lack of
Wellness then that or today's reality in
our country
we cannot accept that Healthcare
disparities are inevitable
and we absolutely cannot accept that the
idea
the idea that meeting the meeting and
eliminating these challenges is too
costly or too difficult
nursing is Americans most trusted
profession
tens of millions of people are counting
on us to create a new Health Care system
in this country to focus on improving
the health of all people
we are the voice and the advocates for
those who have no voices
we are Yale School of Nursing
we will be the clinicians and Advocates
and voices that inspire a transformation
in Americans health health
so thank you very much and welcome to
the next Century of Yale School of
Nursing
thank you
it's now I met my real pleasure to
introduce our special guest
Dr Rajiv Shah is president of the
Rockefeller Foundation which made the
grant as you heard previously that
established Yale School of Nursing
centuries ago
the Rockefeller Foundation believed in
advanced nurse practice for nurses when
the concept doesn't didn't even exist no
one knew about it so a very pioneering
very very innovative
and the foundation continues to identify
and support transformative changes
across human and planetary Health please
join me in welcoming Dr Shaw
thank you
so much
uh good afternoon everyone how are you
just out of curiosity how many students
are here
oh good well thank you for being here in
particular and for taking on the mission
you're taking on thank you president
salave for that outstanding set of
remarks and for sharing with us why you
care so much and have in your family for
generations and thank you Dean amami for
inaugurating the new century for this
great school and for your extraordinary
leadership that I know will help this
school reach even higher Heights so it's
really exciting to be here and it's
great to be with this community and to
honor a little bit of our shared history
in many ways the Rockefeller foundation
and the Yale School of Nursing were
founded for the same reason
effectively to use science and the
frontiers of science to improve the
health of everyone
and in fact before the foundation was
even Incorporated in 1913 John D
Rockefeller senior gave more than a
million dollars to try to eradicate
hookworm a treatable disease that
affected
remember this number more than 40
percent of people living in the American
South
the result of that work which created an
infrastructure at the time called the
general education board resulted in
creating America's county-based Public
Health infrastructure
that work also provided the basic
protocol for the Rockefeller
foundation's Global Public Health
campaigns which began thereafter and
targeted a number of important
infectious diseases
the goal of those campaigns were all
about making health and the access to
health more Equitable in particular for
vulnerable communities
back then the definition of vulnerable
Community was very large because the
application of Science in medicine in
nursing and in public health was
haphazard and unorganized and while I am
not the author as you can tell of the
original report the president made
reference to I think the indictment of
medicine and Health Sciences at the turn
of the last century was that it was not
a science-based discipline and the
foundation worked with institutions
across the world to create a
science-based discipline
within all of the extraordinary
inequities that existed in health in the
United States and around the world at
that time nurses were a bright spot
we've heard about Annie Goodrich and the
extraordinary history she's had but I am
new to her story and so it was it was
fun for me to learn that she became a
nurse before the turn of the century
and as nursing superintendent when the
first world war broke out she warned
that the U.S army was deeply unprepared
and it would lead to significant
competitive disadvantage
as a result she was chosen to organize
and lead the Army School of Nursing as
its first ever Dean for which she
received the distinguished service medal
probably the first
nurse to receive that medal
after her service to the Army she of
course came here and founded this
amazing School
the Yale School of Nursing under her
leadership was founded with a 150
thousand dollar five-year Grant from the
Rockefeller Foundation
I asked president salafi kids if he
could start a school today for 150 000.
he said no
and we did a little math and we learned
that we think that's about 2.7 or 2.8
million dollars in today's money and
just a few years later at the end of
that Grant when the foundation reviewed
the progress of the mission which was
bringing science and educational
discipline and lifting up the Baseline
education process for nurses and nursing
they decided it was so successful they
awarded another one million dollar
endowment which really allowed the
school to flourish we think that's about
18 million dollars in today's money I
also asked the president if you could
start a school today for 18 million he
said no
uh
so Yale and the foundation learned
together
that nursing was in fact the key to
Public Health in the United States in
that window of time
to me that's a lesson that I think is
extraordinarily relevant today
uh for I know how many of you as
students here have put your efforts and
energies into Global Health which is
where the foundation spends a lot a lot
of its resources today and we've seen
over the last 15 or 20 years
extraordinary progress just to give you
one example about the turn of the
century around 2000 there were about
nine to ten million children under the
age of five who died every year mostly
of easily preventable causes and almost
entirely in developing nations that
number was effectively cut in half until
about a few years ago and has been
steadily creeping up each of the last
few years and the truth is this week is
we call it climate week or the
sustainable development goals week in
New York at the United Nations and it's
been pretty Grim to look at the numbers
because over the last few years we're
systematically unwinding years even
Decades of progress in fighting hunger
fighting poverty and certainly in our
common mission of standing up for Health
Equity and international Public Health
and so now more than ever we have to
recognize that nurses are once again
have always been a bright spot in the
fight
from those of you who helped vaccinate
migrant transgender and other vulnerable
people against covid-19 in India to
those who are tracking maternal and
newborn Health using new digital Tools
in Uganda to those who administered PCR
tests to Afghan refugees right here in
New Haven your point of service point of
leadership and points of science are the
hopes we have for changing the status of
health and Public Health at home and
around the world that Insight which was
true many many years ago is still true
today and so it's a real honor to get to
be with you and celebrate your history
and it's even more exciting to get to be
here and participate in a conversation
where we'll talk about your future
because I believe now more than ever
with the pace of Technology the pace of
science new tools related to artificial
intelligence and new realities about a
society
slowly but steadily opening up to
include everybody what this school has
stood for its values its commitments its
science and its people will be more
transformational in this Century to come
thank you
[Applause]
I think that our microphones are on do
you hear us well okay great
so I would like to begin to by thanking
both of you for your very powerful
inspirational remarks thank and thank
you very much for being with us today to
discuss very important topic that I
think that's many of us are very
interested to learn more about yeah so
before we uh start our conversation I
just would like to share with you that
after our conversation there will be
opportunities for the audience to ask
questions so while we are carrying out
our conversation please start thinking
about what are the topics that you would
like to uh ask or or special guests here
today
yeah
yeah I would like to begin with my first
questions to both of you
100 years ago the Rockefeller Foundation
funded the Yale School of Nursing at the
first academic as the first academic
nursing school in this country
we are honored to be here 100 years
later talking about the importance of
how this work and this Workforce has
evolved and progressed
so for each of you what is the most
surprising change you have witnessed
or heard about in the profession of
Nursing
who would like to start
I'm happy to start I you know I get to
see I ran a federal agency called usaid
for President Obama U.S agency for
International Development and so I've
had a chance to see nursing and nurse
and the practice of Nursing in societies
around the world and the thing I find is
that the secret transformation that's
happening is if you go to a village in
Northern India or a Islam outside of
Nairobi where some of us just were a few
weeks ago called kabira you will meet
nurses who are taking their smartphones
and an extraordinary amount of
Technology with them to the interface
with patients and it is
transforming their capacity to address
malnutrition to identify disease to
rapidly determine how to triage
communities and making them frankly ever
more powerful and ever more successful
there's an outstanding long piece today
and or yesterday maybe in the New York
Times about the community health workers
which of course are not anywhere near
the high level of Yale educated School
of Nursing graduates but I think there's
going to be a trend over time with the
democratization of knowledge information
and Technology
at the point of service and the point of
care so that over time we'll finally be
able to reach absolutely everyone with
the ethic and spirit of nursing with
which the school was founded which is
the country at the time needed 50 000
nurses had 11
000 and was asking itself how could you
quickly
generate 40 000 additional super skilled
highly trained professionals
I think that's the kind of thinking we
need today in countries around the world
if we're to turn around the
reality that we're losing ground on
fighting malarial deaths or dealing with
under five mortality or have an increase
in neonatal
mortality in in many settings and even
just dealing with the extraordinary
disparities in this country that Dean
you mentioned in your opening part of
your remarks so that's the thing I'm
both most excited about and most
surprised by is how pervasive that
access to technology is going to be when
it really hits
thank you
so uh let me answer that question in a
little different way and I don't know if
surprise is the emotion but certainly
surprised and thrilled
is is the emotion that I feel when I
think about this
so when I was an undergraduate I took a
class called medical sociology and one
of the interesting aspects of medical
sociology as taught in the 1970s
was a set of experiments field
experiments done mostly in the 50s and
early 60s
on status
and the health professionals Health
Professions
and they typically set up a situation
in which a a nurse would discover in a
hospital setting
that a physician had ordered the wrong
dose of a medication
or had you know set out or delivered the
wrong dose
and in various ways these there's a
whole set of experiments in various ways
the question was would the nurse
confront the physician and say you've
got the wrong drug here you've got the
wrong amount of this drug here
and in the 1950s again and again what
was demonstrated is the nurses all knew
there was a mistake
and many of them didn't say anything
and this was taught in the in the in
hell in the sociology of Health as an
example of status and Status
characteristics some of it was gendered
some of it was professional status and
how it could lead
this status Consciousness could lead to
mistakes in in healthcare
what's wonderful
and surprising isn't the right word but
thrilling is you couldn't replicate
those studies today you couldn't get
that result today
the way in which nurses are incorporated
as equal members of a team
respected as a profession and are
expected
to say sorry doc you don't have that
right
I saw it myself when I was a psychology
intern at the West Haven VA hospital
just a couple of decades later
and I I'm that says a lot about the
profession it says a lot about education
it says a lot about the kinds of people
attracted to nursing says a lot about
um
gender equality
and I think it's a of course
results in the delivery of safer and
better health care for everyone
great answers thank you
the next question is to all of us
actually and I would like to answer it
first
good idea following you
[Laughter]
so
what is the one Baseline Improvement you
see as critical to Better Health in the
United States and then internationally
and I have been thinking about it for
for a long time and I I would like to
say that the most critical Baseline
based on my opinion is a universal
healthcare access to everyone
um through affordable
um care and with a very sharp focus on
prevention health promotion
that will be done through very strong
primary care and of course delivered by
nurses
so what about yeah you know I would I
would answer in a very similar way there
is no doubt uh that the economics of
Health Care would be improved
dramatically if we put more emphasis on
prevention uh and uh you know as a as a
psychologist I know that as a nurse
professional many of you know that uh
the the most expensive things to thing
to do is to fix problems after they
happen rather than prevent them and so
the emphasis on behavior and lifestyle
factors environmental factors and the
prevention of illness before it happens
um it's partly what's going to I think
save our our Health Care system in this
country so I you know I I think we have
to really
reorient
around a a prevention model rather than
a a a a model focused on on repair
yeah I'll agree with that but use maybe
different words I I think I think
Wellness is the and and the science of
wellness and achieving Wellness will
ultimately be the path to help address
large-scale improvements in population
Health particularly in the United States
Eileen O'Connor is is with me she's a a
former Yale uh administrator and leader
here so we were excited to come here
together but during covid we we worked
and through Eileen helped worked with
the Yale School of Nursing and with Yale
University on testing access in our
country and you won't you you might not
remember this but in in March and April
of 2020 you know actually testing was
not commonly available the United States
had rejected through the CDC a South
Korean testing format and our own format
was faulty and the government at the
highest level of our federal government
was actually against testing right and
so
you know that that's a good example of
just if you if you sat and asked
yourself how would you get hundreds of
millions of tests manufactured give
people the confidence to use them just
to track their own uh health and
wellness uh that's the kind of question
that I think we're going to be dealing
with over and over today at the
foundation when we look to the Future
really coming out of the covet
experience where America had the highest
excess mortality of Any Nation on the
planet in covid which is absurd in a
country that puts as the president made
brief reference to more than four
trillion dollars a year in our in our
Healthcare economy we think sustained
Wellness the reduction of large-scale
chronic disease that made Americans so
vulnerable to mortality is going to be
the only viable answer and it'll be you
in this room that developed the the
science but also the the way the
pathways so that people can listen here
engage and participate in keeping
themselves healthy so they're not as
vulnerable as we've been in the past
thank you Dr Shaw noting that the
foundation has invested heavily in
Solutions related to climate change
under your leadership what do you see as
the connection between climate and human
health and could you give us some
success stories that you feel the
foundation or your partners or other
organizations have had related to
climate and health
well well first I I heard the president
your your reference to planetary health
and I'm really glad to hear that the
School of Nursing is actively engaged in
you know understanding the correlation
between planetary Health boundaries and
human health boundaries I think if you
look at climate change it's going to
have a few major dislocations for
large-scale population Health the first
is we just came out of a once in a
century pandemic
you can expect those much more
frequently because the pressures that
expose populations to pandemic threats
like zoonotic pressure will be much much
higher as the climate changes a second
is we know we're going to have much more
infectious disease in many more places
than we do today that's already very
obvious so the 50-year history we've had
of a relative decline in infectious
disease mortality morbidity is going to
have sustained upward pressure now
because of climate over the next next
bit of time a third is heat and heat I
mean I was with these women that are
Salt Flat workers and in the desert in
Northern Gujarat in India and they're
working in 40 degrees Centigrade heat
and it is it's deadly to do that they're
already
poorly nourished and they're already the
most vulnerable and so the combination
of heat and vulnerability will will
yield extraordinary consequences and the
final one that I don't think most people
realize is there's going to be a 30
percent reduction in agricultural
productivity caused by a changing
climate and you know if you look at just
the path for hunger and the underlying
hidden hunger or malnutrition and
micronutrient malnutrition that you all
are experts on then most people don't
know about
it's going to make people much more
vulnerable to all of this in the future
so I think there are some big threats
the good news is you're on top of it
we'll count on your science and your
insights and your ability to get people
to behave differently to keep themselves
protected but but that's why I really
believe your work is more needed for the
next Century than the past one I I don't
think I can add to that answer that was
just a fabulous answer other than to say
it is very fortunate that Yale has a
school of nursing a School of Public
Health a school of medicine a school of
the environment
departments in Arts and Sciences and in
engineering and applied sciences
concerned with the environment concerned
with
climate change
uh and beyond all of that because it is
going to take a multi-disciplinary
approach to solve these problems yes we
all have our particular emphases and
expertise but it's going to be working
across boundaries whether those
boundaries are international
or disciplinary
to to address these problems sometimes I
think
as a long time
academic that the international
boundaries may be easier to transcend
than the disciplinary ones and that
would be too bad and I think we're
trying to model
a more unified approach here at Yale to
addressing I think the most profound
problem of our lifetime
so I would like to follow on what you
just shared and because I know that
during your tenure Yale has invested
campus-wide in in climate issues through
the planetary solution project and could
you more specifically comment what role
nursing could because I I know the the
interdisciplinary you know collaboration
and the challenge that that you just
alluded to so
and we have a very you know strong
platform in the school of nursing for
planetary health I would like to hear
your thoughts about how nursing could
play a an important role yeah yeah I
think there's many roles that nursing
can play in in um in addressing climate
Solutions
planetary Solutions uh let me just give
a couple
um
first of all there is such a strong
emphasis in this nursing school and at
Yale on on global Health you are already
all over the world
you are already collaborating with
investigators and clinicians and
Educators all over the world and you do
that in ways that transcend some of the
political
barriers so for example Yale School of
Nursing has worked in China for a long
time politically
we're at a a tense moment between the
two countries
in in reality
climate change is not addressed without
China and the us working together just
can't
these two enormous economies uh have to
collaborate that's really hard to do
right now at a political level
but nurses in China and nurses at Yale
can work together on projects and you
know when I'm in when I'm in Washington
I visit Capitol Hill
and I talked to senators and members of
the House
usually who have a Yale degree but
they're on both sides of the aisle
right and I say I bring up China I'm
just using China as an example I bring
up China
most of the most of the time you get the
current view right which is quite
negative
and you get it from both sides of the
aisle and then I say do you know we have
dual degree programs in China we have
nurses working in China collaborating on
on capacity building projects and
educational projects we have a center in
Beijing for the University as a whole
run by the School of Management etc etc
we have joint degree programs I say
do you think we should pull out of all
of that every one of them
on both sides says no no no stay
involved please stay involved
and I think that's because at some level
they recognize
that we have to look toward the future
we have huge Global problems to solve
and we're not going to solve them in
isolation so the nurses already doing
that Yale School of Nursing is already
already doing it and I guess the other
I'll just mention one other way
you're seeing
signs and symptoms and patient Behavior
often before we know what we're what it
is that we're observing
right the way in which nurses are
trained to observe
and to observe whole humans and to
observe Behavior
and to observe the kinds of measurable
signs and symptoms that that we use in
healthcare
means that
those powers of observation that
training when put to use is going to
sound alarms
often before
we know what's what's happening we know
what it is
uh and that that's kind of a
what would you call it Sentinel function
maybe a sentinel function
so bring up Sentinel functions on our
Centennial
try to keep that straight and um uh you
know but it's a role it's a role that
Primary Care Providers are always going
to play you will see it
even before as a society we know what it
is and that's going to be very very
important as we confront new diseases or
old diseases appearing in new places as
the climate changes
thank you
so as both of you very eloquently
remarked on in in your speeches about
how the covid-19 global pandemic uh
show the world the heroic um you know
impact of of nurses and what nurses do
it was really wonderful for for all uh
us nurses to have that recognition but
now we are facing a backlash in in not
only the United States but globally
there is a huge shortage of nurses and I
think that part of his is due to Bernard
because you know in a couple of years
the work really the nursing work was
really devastating and and so
what do you think we could do to address
now the nursing shortage crisis uh what
are the are the ideas that you might
have for well let me mention too okay
just two
nurses
who are educated as As Leaders as
you know for the nursing profession like
here at Yale uh have typically gone to
college and and then have gone to
graduate school
and they amass a lot of debt
at Yale we've been very much trying over
the last decade to increase access to an
education
and at this University the highest the
students with the highest debt on
graduation it it's not all from Yale
that's for sure
but the students with the highest debt
on graduation are our nursing students
wow that has to end
that has to end if we want to see more
people go into the profession
I don't come from a wealthy family as
you probably figured out from the video
and from my comments about my family but
it is why we did a scholarship here in
the school of nursing as as the first
endowment I hope the first among others
that that that we can do and it was
really my parents who I when when I was
in our greatest president my mother
called and she said we want to give you
a gift
for becoming president what do you need
I need a new camera
they got me a camera when I graduated
from college
I don't need anything
they said well we want to get you a gift
I said well figure out something you
could do for Yale and do it for yell at
the level that you can do it my dad was
a chemistry professor my mother was a
nurse as you heard
I said figure out a level that you can
do it and they came up with the idea
we're going to do a scholarship at Yale
and we're going to do it in the nursing
school because we know nurses have a lot
of debt and because mom's a nurse
and that's what they did and then we've
tried to add more to it and friends have
added more to it and
the like
but I think if that we don't have to
tell
I don't tell that story for your
applause I tell that story because it's
a story that if we could tell more
broadly
others would follow others would do not
not they would do their own version of
this
they just don't know they don't know how
high the debt uh uh is I said I was
going to talk about two things we need
to do but I talked long enough so let me
yield to uh
uh I I don't have anything to add beyond
that except that there should be you
know I've always wondered why and I
think this is a higher education
question when there's so much sustained
demand
for something that's so critical to
society
here and around the world why can't
there be more Supply so you know I don't
know whether that means bigger schools
of nursing or more schools of nursing
certainly in global health and on a
global basis we desperately need many
many many more institutions that bring
what Yale brings to to nursing here all
over the planet and and you know any
estimate that you look at in terms of
where people will where the needs will
be for society over time
there's a much greater share of human
labor that will go into the caring
economy for those that look at it that
way in the future than than in the past
and in a professionalized compensated
manner as opposed to in the informal
economy so I just think there's a supply
demand mismatch and I don't have enough
expertise to know why there aren't so
many more schools of nursing
unfortunately the Rockefeller Foundation
if we could start schools for a hundred
fifty thousand dollars
today we do it all over the planet I
promise but but we can't yeah and I'll
say one one more thing the the the uh
when when we when it was February and
certainly March April May
2020.
what what happened
this this uh virus that we didn't know
much about starting to move across the
planet arrives in the U.S I remember
when the first
Community transmitted case in
Connecticut
arrived when we our students went home
for spring break and we told them stay
there
um
nurses went to work
theirs is just went to work
and they they you know we're trying to
keep everybody else out of the hospital
nurses went into the hospital and into
the clinics
and um
get a little emotional about this the
when I saw those signs at Yale New Haven
Hospital for example
that said Heroes work here
it was an amazing recognition
of what it meant to be doing that kind
of work day in and day out during
this pandemic particularly in those
early months when we didn't I mean we we
didn't know it was going to kill
everybody who it touched it was
certainly killing people
we knew
and so uh you know that Heroes welcome
Heroes work here signs
may just made me think how can we make
sure
that our children that our society
recognize what this work is like day in
and day out because if we do that not
only will it be more attractive
uh to kids to go into
but it will but burnout will will be
lowered right people there's lots of
things that cause burnout and and
sometimes it's some very bread and
butter things but sometimes it's just I
wish people knew what it is like to walk
on my shoes and people should know what
it was like to be a nurse in the early
days of the pandemic
um it was to be a hero yet no nurse
thought of themselves as a hero they
just thought they were going to work
and it was very impressive
and we know that the number of lost
lives among nurses was the highest among
all the front line you know providers
during the pandemic and despite your
excitement president salary about the
the the the the the elimination of
you know hierarchical
you know structure in the the healthcare
services that nurses nowadays really you
know can speak up and
if they see more practice or whatever
that is not working in in the healthcare
delivery by physicians but we know that
we are we have still a long way to go
and
um so I I wonder your thoughts about the
the the still you know disparities of of
power pay you know especially in other
countries I think that we have
we have gone a long way in the United
States but generally globally nurses are
usually the lowest paid you know
Healthcare professionals and also you
know even in the United States
um not being able to practice to the
full scope of nurses capability this is
a huge even economic economic ways of
resources so what are your thoughts
about how we can really you know change
um the the public you know image of what
nurses do and why we need to really
Empower nurses to
to practice to uh the the highest scope
of their capabilities and get paid for
it appropriately
well I am pleased to see that this is
changing and I'm not a economist or uh
sociologists who can really answer that
questions but I will say
um
no
movement for change has ever happened I
think without allies and I think the
Allies are going to have to be other
health care providers and in particular
the Ally in
recognizing that nurses who can practice
to their full capability
are the Ally that's going to have to
recognize that the potential like who is
going to have to recognize that to allow
it to happen is organized medicine
and um
it's not a pretty picture historically
and and I you know I don't want to pick
on anybody or any profession
my mother were alive she still would
want me to be a doctor
but but
we can and there's plenty of of
Physicians with a public health
orientation with a collaborative
orientation who are very much champions
of Nursing
but we need more of them to be
and we need the formal organizations
that represent uh Physicians to be
because I I think both of you have said
in your remarks this is part of the
solution nurses are going to be part of
the solution that's true by the way in
my fee in in the mental health field as
well in field of psychology and
Psychiatry as well
thank you very much I think that now we
have few minutes for questions from the
audience and could you please in order
for you to be heard by everyone wait for
the microphone to be delivered to you
yeah I have to find the microphone oh
okay
it's the one on the podium oh under here
thank you this has been Incredible
Journey for all of us
um I love the notion of Primary Health
Care Prime disease you know Primary
Health Care disease prevention
and I think that and just looking it's
not just about promoting Health within
individuals or communities that's
necessary but structural changes that
need to happen
and you know the concept of political
you know constraints that are affecting
people's lives as well as Environmental
and social
um things that are determining how many
of the marginalized communities are
subsisting if you will that we need to
incorporate those Concepts into the work
that we do and just promoting Health in
individual and communities
and that we have to partner with all of
those elements to be able to do that and
Kathy
Gillis yes we were Primary Care policy
fellows together back in the 90s and
that's one of the things I think is so
critical for us to to really start to
work on as well and thank you for this
incredible presentation I appreciate
that
thank you
[Applause]
I am
Richard Jennings class of 79 Midwifery
a little bit off topic
but would you have you considered the
role of guaranteed annual income as a
way to address poverty in the United
States
I I can take the foundation it the
foundation actually has done a lot of
work on different forms of
population level
interventions that can address poverty
child poverty and health improvements
and one of the shocking things we
learned years ago was actually the most
effective
uh Healthcare Access program in recent
American social policy history was the
Earned Income Tax Credit the most which
for those of you know you know is is a
basically a cash transfer to to certain
Working Families the most effective by
far poverty program in the United States
in any recent memory is the refundable
child tax credit and our foundation
actually supported we had this strategy
back in 2018
to support advocating for those two
interventions in red States and blue
States and so even certain states that
didn't have income tax could still have
a refundable child tax credit or earned
income tax credit and then when covid
hit we actually brought all those local
state grantees together to Washington
and had them meet with decision makers
in Congress and in the White House and
of course the part of the coveted
response was the largest social policy
experiment in recent American decades
which was a vastly expanding those two
efforts as part of providing some form
of basic guaranteed income and it was
wildly effective child poverty got cut
in half the minute that went away child
poverty doubled it's just shocking how
pinpoint accurate that was and they're a
Consortium of foundations that studied
all the impacts and found people don't
waste the money
people don't use it for things that are
not considered high value it's mostly
Health Care child care support So
families can be back in the in the labor
force and nutrition for for children and
and so Eileen and her team work every
day to try to build a more robust
political environment that can look at
the data and make rational decisions
we're not quite there yet as a country
um but it it is uh and that's not
specific answer on basic income but
those are those are the biggest
experiments we have with any sort of
Direct Cash transfer that effectively
operates as such
hi good afternoon back to the wellness I
think it was the second question about
Wellness
in the same manner
how do we provide incentives because
everyone in this room and many of us
know that Wellness may be the answer but
if the finances if we're in such a model
of disease and symptom treatment and
that's where the money is for providers
and
people coming out of Middle School
school who also have huge debt and this
is where they're going to make their
money and politically
Pharmaceuticals what are your thoughts
about systemically
it's so easy to say wellness and I've
read the data too about preventable
diseases but what are some real steps
that could be taken to
shift this structure in this country
well speaking of someone who has no
particular expertise on this other than
a little bit about Behavior change in at
the individual level you know
providing incentives for individuals to
make Lifestyle Changes
that are probably built into their
health care coverage
would would be one one level at which to
start but you know when we've tried that
for example I don't know how many of you
are Yale Health members but I get my
health care from Yale Health when we've
tried that where you get you know your
premiums are lower or you don't have to
pay copay whatever when you agree to a
set of Wellness
interventions it's hard to get people to
agree they they resent the threat to
their what they believe is their
autonomy and their freedom and I think
we have to work on that on that problem
and you know individual level incentives
are good but maybe we should try some
group in societal level
incentives to try to encourage people to
to want to engage in in those behaviors
you know I could add two two interesting
experiments that I think offer a path
forward and this can be an area where we
learn from other countries but about 20
years ago in Mexico they had a program
called progressa I don't know how many
of you are familiar with that but they
offered conditional cash transfers as
president salave just said to you know
incentivize certain behaviors and
they're not dramatically large cash
transfers but they encouraged you know a
certain number of prenatal visits and
postnatal visits and other kinds of
preventative oriented interventions and
they were extraordinarily effective just
it was a behavioral economics reality
that they were extremely effective and
and some of those efforts got scaled
around the world Bangladesh Kenya and
and we saw
so we saw such significant results that
we even brought some of those to
Baltimore and Detroit and places in the
U.S where they've also been effective so
so I think there's evidence for that
basic approach the other effort we just
started as a major partnership with the
American Heart Association called food
is medicine and in that context insurers
have been supporting experiments to
identify whether dietary interventions
can in fact reduce hemoglobin A1c levels
in pre-diabetic and diabetic populations
and it's been so effective that we're
scaling scaling that up and doing a big
National study to explore that as a
basic approach to reducing the financial
pressure we spend 300 billion dollars a
year on Diabetes Care in the United
States
nearly all of which is preventable and
it's basically a dietary disease as you
know so you know but it is unfortunate
that for all of these types of things
you're up against some reality and and
the reality we're up against is we spend
trillions of dollars every year
in a very treatment intervention
oriented after the fact medical system
that proved to be
extremely ineffective during the covet
pandemic in protecting Americans lives
yeah there's so many little
demonstration experiments that that we
can learn from right here in New Haven
uh there was a uh a program to encourage
Community gardening
uh and it teamed up with a program to
encourage healthy eating so that the
community when you went to your
community garden learned how to grow in
an urban setting uh often very Urban
setting when you learned how to grow
things that you could eat you then also
learned how to cook them in the
healthiest way
and what have you so that that those are
very small little interventions very
local but but um but that's maybe a good
place for it to begin I'm also reading
right now
many of you know our professor Tim
Snyder Tim is the world's expert really
on the history of Eastern Europe the
Baltic region and now Russia and Ukraine
and many of you have seen him on the
news and his course on the history of
Ukraine is is online for anybody to take
and is very very good at people tell me
that they appreciate it all the time but
Tim wrote a little book A couple of
years ago I think it's called our malady
and it comes out of his experience of
being a patient with a
life-threatening disease or
life-threatening condition
uh but but being that's how it starts
and these were his Diaries but then he
reflects on
how care was delivered to him all over
the world because he travels the world
he and his family
and the example I just happened to read
in the last couple of days was I think
it was
either the Netherlands or Austria I
can't remember now
where you get a little when you're when
you get your prenatal care you get a
little passport thing that looks like a
passport and every time you
um you get you do a a prenatal visit it
gets a stamp in the Box for that visit
after you have a baby you get stamps for
the for well baby visits uh and the like
and as you accumulate these stamps
other health care needs that you might
have are deep are more deeply discounted
yeah right and all you have to do is
show your passport with all these stamps
in them so it doesn't require great
technological intervention but you show
your passport if they're stamped
when you need something done in the
Healthcare System it's less expensive
for you right it was the simplest kind
of intervention
and apparently everybody does it because
it is simple
see there you have it you're doing
Wellness prevention and it's getting you
something in addition to a longer
healthier life uh fairly immediately
I I would like to add to uh you know in
addition to individual incentives that
that
you both alluded to I think that the
systemic changes and also what Dr Shaw
uh suggested about really learning from
the the other countries that have a much
more focus on prevention and promotion
and that has shown how they can reduce
and they have reduced their you know
Health Care Services costs and the
health outcomes of are much much better
and so I think that we we need to also
focus more on policy changes on you know
political determinants of of Health we
focus a lot on social determinants of
Health but I think that what we miss is
that uh you know the root cause of a lot
of you know uh poor outcomes in this
country goes back to the political
determinants of health and how the
decisions that are made really you know
prevents Healthcare Providers and
Healthcare Systems to uh to you know
care more about the the health outcomes
of of all the people and so thank you
yeah
I want to thank all of you for a really
inspirational your talks and your
comments about past and future and to
follow up Dr mommy in terms of uh and
the passport issue when I was doing
research in the UK all women in the UK
carry their prenatal record themselves
for the entire pregnancy
and uh no backup you know it was just
pre-electronic record but no backup and
I remember asking
um I was I
um as an ethnographer I said well don't
they ever lose it and they said
of course not we lose it much more than
they do and then they said why would she
lose it that's her baby that's her
future and so that inevitable trust in
the people that we're caring for is so
incredibly important but that's not my
question
my question is
as has been said we spend so much money
on health care and yet we have so our
primary providers uh on the front lines
are limited we don't have enough
and and we certainly don't have enough
midwives
and it's not just having more spaces in
schools we can't we turn away students
because we don't have enough clinical
sites and one of the reasons we don't
have enough clinical sites is there's
not an investment in this country in
graduate nursing education it's a huge
investment in medical education so I'd
ask you to say what what could we do to
upend at that because I think it is
about being able to help people have
access to the marvelous education in so
many schools and especially at Yale
[Applause]
thank you
well I don't know the answer but I'd say
this if there was ever a moment in
recent history where the basic
importance
of nursing Primary Care
massively scaling up diagnostic capacity
in this country
and democratizing access to basic health
interventions
was seen and felt by everyone it was the
covid pandemic and and I don't actually
know I'm sure there's expertise in this
room but but it feels like coming out of
covet if we really look at why did
America have the most excess mortality
against modeled predictions the answer
was America has the least investment on
a relative basis in good primary care we
don't value it as much as we should we
don't pay people as much as we should in
that space we don't build infrastructure
as much we don't even have enough
diagnostic testing capacity that reaches
every community
and and that on a relative basis is not
that expensive to fix
relative to you know the trillions of
dollars that we spend on on other parts
of the Health Care system so
this feels like our moment you know to
make that case
okay hi I'm Lauren Nelson I am the
associate dean of global Affairs and
planetary health
first want to welcome and honor Danny
mommy for accepting to lead our school
as we enter into the next 100 Years
thank you
I also want to thank president salave
and Dr Shaw for being here to celebrate
the Centennial with us and for offering
your thoughts on the future of nursing
at Yale my question is for you Dr Shaw I
appreciated uh reading your commentary
that you published last summer online
which talked about the Rockefellers
foundations interests in addressing the
human toll of the climate crisis as
you've already heard it's something that
we're trying to prepare nurses Nurse
midwives nurse practitioners scientists
and leaders to contribute to their
response as well
one of the things that we also think a
lot about here as it relates to the
frequency of extreme weather events goes
beyond the tragic death tolls but really
to the scale of the post-traumatic
stress effects that will occur in a
global mental health in the context of
global mental health infrastructure that
is brittle
maybe to say to the lease and many low
and middle income countries
we know that the need to have
community-wide Wellness is going to be
key to any real sustainable recovery
whether it's social political or
economic and communities across the
planet what I'd like to know if you
could offer us any thoughts from the
foundation about the role of promoting
Global mental Wellness as a strategy for
human adaptation in the context of this
current climate crisis yeah what a great
great question as would be expected from
Yale
as you know I mean mental health is the
is the fastest growing
source of morbidity by the according to
the who on a planetary basis and if you
look specifically at climate and the
estimates you know you have
the number of hungry Communities going
from about 700 million people to 1.4
billion people you have 200 million
climate migrants that's a lot of
disruption in in conflict and political
strife and in human
well-being so I think in general mental
health has to be a much bigger part of
the assessment and the response kit for
Nations that are trying to prepare for
what their Public Health infrastructure
looks like in the future unfortunately
right now most of the countries that are
most acutely hit are going through
effectively a debt crisis of what
happened during covid was
we poured 30 plus percent of GDP
effectively in monetary and fiscal
stimulus into our economy and it created
a floor they didn't couldn't do that in
81 countries that house most of the
world's most vulnerable people and and
as a result right now if you go to Kenya
62 percent of their public budget is
paying off interest gone I think it's 74
and that's true in 40 plus countries and
so at a time when they should be
investing in what you're describing and
planning for the future they're actually
cutting back on Health Services which is
why these numbers are getting worse
instead of better on on basic things
like maternal mortality child mortality
and infectious disease prevalence so
there's a big financing problem and it's
great to hear that you have enough of a
culture of interdisciplinary problem
solving that you can you know bring your
expertise from here together with policy
teams that work on those issues
um but it clearly has to be a very very
big part of of planning proper planning
for public health in the future has to
be redefined in a much much broader way
that's that's Global and local so if you
if you live in New Haven like like I do
you know a big part of the city's budget
is servicing debt yeah and uh making up
for underfunded pensions pension
programs and it's only after you
pay for those that you begin to think
about you know what could we do to
promote the wellness of our uh of our
population
unfortunately we have time for only one
more question
so I think I saw somebody over here
careful careful
Carol McKenzie Class of 73 maternally
born in nurse Midwifery I live in rural
East Texas
as someone unenlightened political state
with horrible maternal newborn outcomes
and I guess my question is and also
Advanced nurse practitioners do not have
full Authority so if you look at all of
those issues how do you navigate the
incredibly horrible political landscape
without causing a political brouhaha
here but foreign
let me try
[Applause]
but I'll ask others to help
yeah well there is I I actually think
there are potential Solutions on both
sides of the political aisles so for
example
we and we try and do support
policy analysis and advocacy and
Innovation on both sides of political
aisle but
the there ought to be a movement to
deregulate
the medical certification
rule structure so that labor can be
rewarded
for the value it can generate right at
every level and that's a that's a pretty
if that from first principles that's a
fairly conservative argument and we
found some very conservative Republican
Partners would advocate for that with us
alongside some more Progressive
communities that want to eliminate
Health disparities and what and have a
different way of coming at the same
problem
and so you know I mentioned what I
mentioned about the earned income tax
credit that was actually created by
Richard Nixon in a conservative policy
context as the first negative income tax
in the United States and so shockingly
there are areas where where you can make
progress but they do seem to be dwarfed
by the noise and and the noise is only
going to get more noisy over the course
of the next year but but the underlying
Point you're making is until everyone
can be freed to use their skills to help
their communities be well and be
rewarded for that and not be constrained
by rules that are effectively Guild
structure
political fighting
you know we're not going to have the
workforce we need unleash the way we
need to to do it and frankly I
personally think that the application of
AI and other forms of technology will
put even more pressure on that system
because you'll find people who believe
they
uniquely own some Grand expertise
we'll find that that becomes less and
less possible when your phone can do
what you used to do
that's crazy
very very sad you know I think a lot of
this is you talked about Texas a lot of
this is due to the incredible political
polarization that we see in our country
right now some of the most important
legislative approaches to Health Care
delivery broadly speaking we're
bipartisan efforts I think who in the
Senate
sponsored the Family Leave Act who are
the two main co-sponsors of the fam the
original Family Leave Act
anybody remember
Ted Kennedy that's one who is the other
one
Orrin Hatch
okay right so you had
one of the most liberal members of the
Senate one of the most conservative
members of the Senate why do they come
together and do that first of all they
were friends
they actually can have a civil
conversation with each other
second of all they saw in Family Leave
Act Kennedy probably saw different
things that
produce the same ends or were produced
by the same end
Kennedy sees a safety net program
guaranteeing jobs hatch sees
family-friendly legislation guaranteeing
parent is going to be home at least in
those early months or weeks of a child's
life and so they both can get behind
this
this program
why don't we see that today there's a
lot of reasons why we don't see that
today two of them are
gerrymandered political districts that
make everybody worried that they're
going to be challenged by somebody who's
more extreme in their in their District
than they are because that's who votes
in primaries and so they run to the
extremes
reject overtures by the other party
because it looks weak and because they
worry about their electability
and maybe the way rich media is
polarized and every every issue gets a
has a uh you're either force or against
us kind of quality to the analysis uh
that we hear maybe that will change I
think we as members of the public have
to kind of demand that kind of change
but I think we'll see more of the kind
of legislation that has led to
programs that
uh of the time we would all like to like
in the health area if both parties could
get behind them because there is
something for both parties in most of
them
yeah
that I think that's although the the
divisive of the you know political
um climate right now in this country we
we shouldn't underestimate the power of
community organization and advocacy I
think that a lot of changes
transformational changes that have
happened throughout the history of the
United States and also other countries
uh if you look back it they are resulted
of the community engagement that
Community organization and and that I
would like to look at our our students
here because I think that nurses could
play an important role part of our job
as a nurse is advocacy and then we need
to really learn more to be engaged and
add to really be the voice of of people
who are not having the voice and that
could also impact the change in the the
political climate of this country so
that is something that I would like to
see more in our nursing profession and
our next generation of nurses will
definitely
do that for us
for sure
so first of all I would like to thank
our special guests for a very
wide-ranging rich conversation and thank
you very much the audience for our your
thought-provoking questions and your
engagement thank you very much I think
that we all learned a lot and we are all
inspired after this very rich
conversation and so at this point of
time I would like to ask president
Sullivan to join me to the podium
because I think that we have an
announcement here and I think you're
going to make it I'm going to clap
[Laughter]
this event and also for me just joining
the Yale School of Nursing and have this
privilege and honor to make this
announcement nothing could be better as
a thought for my deanship here and so
we would like to make the announcement
about the just recently an anonymous
donor has recently finalized a very very
generous gift to Yale School of Nursing
in honor of our Centennial
and the gift will directly impact the
students we talked about uh you know the
debt and the cost of the education and
those type of gifts are so amazing and
so so transformative for us to be able
to not only attract the the
highly qualified
nursing students but also really
diversify our our programs
um so and this gift will be an endowment
um to provide six full-ride scholarship
every year starting from this year so
it's nothing no promise for for future
but right now we can invent use it and
this is the largest single donation we
have received in the Yale School of
Nursing and the total gift is
11.1 million dollars
so of course I'm very happy and very
excited about this wonderful opportunity
but I would like to thank everyone else
beside me because I was not a part of
this coming through
so thank you very much it was definitely
a team work off of many years in making
and a lot of people have been involved
and so wonderful wonderful opportunity
for our school wonderful opportunity for
our students so thank you very much
so I so I read I was looking at Dean
script and it says and now president
Sullivan would like to share some
additional good news
I wonder what that is
and I thought it would be the news about
matching so as you know uh the Provost
and I uh and Scott Strobel our Provost
is here with us today uh pledged that we
would use University funds to match uh
the first 50 million dollars raised by
this school uh in the for Humanity
campaign so that 11.1 is at 11.1 yes
million dollars have to get the math
exactly right that 11.1 million dollars
becomes 22.2 million dollars
thank you
because it's amazing it's wonderful
great and we hope it inspires others and
I'm talking to our friends watching
through the power yes yes
of YouTube right now yes and and when I
heard about this news I just felt don't
feel any pressure it's just how can I uh
you know match that in my you know we
have until 2026 I think to end the
campaign and hopefully we are going to
this major gift will inspire a lot of
our our friends and and donors it sure
will and all joking aside we couldn't be
more grateful uh to to our Anonymous
donor for this incredible act and these
are dollars that will go very far in the
School of Nursing and will help with
that debt issue that we were talking
about uh earlier today so thank you very
much and thank you to anyone who is able
to contribute we recognize not always at
that level
but in any way thank you thanks very
much
[Applause]
I would like to close our celebration
today with a round of applause to for
Centennial committee
please join me and thank them for
helping me
committee represents a wide range of
volunteers to really help and worked
very hard tirelessly in 18 months to
planning and organizing all the events
the celebrations and everything that is
going to happen throughout the this year
and some of those amazing volunteers are
today with us in this room so I would
like to ask you to stand up to be
recognized if you are here as I I'm
reading your name Janine Baden
Helen burst
Elizabeth Doyle
oh my goodness Melissa galinado
black greeter
poly Powell Kennedy
Michelle Koss
Circle
Nancy cross
Gail my college
Karen Morelli
Caroline pizzelli
Heather Reynolds
[Applause]
hahaha
I also would like to thank Michelle
Morgan and Tipsy pigs crew for their
videography Services here today and HP
live for their broadcast support and our
event manager Michelle cost again for
making all the behind the scene magics
I'm also grateful to Hilary Dooley Julia
pafford Mike Reagan and Taylor and
testoni on our office of development and
alumni relations for all the
contributions that made it to today's
very successful day for us
and last but not least I would like to
thank both or our special guest thank
you very much for carving out of your
very very busy time to come here and
have this wonderful discussion this is a
great
initiation of our year-long celebration
so Dr Shaw if you join me now here so
that I could present with you a small
token of here
or our appreciation for for your time
thank you very much
exactly
foreign